- Wait, what if boba is bad for you?
(murmuring)
I'm gonna Google it.
(cheerful music)
- Why are Asians lactose intolerant?
- Asian glow remedies.
- What to wear to a Korean
one year old's birthday party.
- How do you say happy
birthday in Cantonese?
- Best sushi, Los Angeles.
- Best dim sum near me.
- Authentic Pakistani food in Los Angeles.
- Does cupping really work?
- Those Asian rice crackers
you eat when you're a baby.
- Is Haleeb milk the same as Golden milk?
- Average height for Asian guy.
(beeping)
- How to do monolid makeup.
- Glasses for Asian people.
- Korean makeup routine,
10 steps?
- Dry earwax Asian.
- What is first generation?
Am I first generation?
- Descendants of the Sun online free.
- Can all Filipino people dance?
- Dance lessons.
- When is Lunar New Year?
(beeping) I gotta call my mom.
- Home remedies for clear skin.
- Is Bruno Mars Asian?
- Is Nicki Minaj Asian?
- Is Emma Stone even a little bit Asian?
- Why can't real Asians
play Asian characters?
- Is she like Chinese?
She have like a
Russian grandfather
who was from the south?